i don't know how people start these but
apparently a lot of people want to see
the inside of my closet
that's the thing and there's we're
running out of tv shows because of the
pandemic so i
frankly have nothing else to do and you
have nothing else to watch so
we're just gonna do this i haven't
really cleaned up
just clean up a little wet towel with
like
funk on it okay here's my closet i'm a
virgo this is like my
actual nightmare how would i
describe my jewelry taste um
santa fe divorcee albuquerque art
teacher
can you guide me because i am bombing
yeah what do you want to start with your
wizard jewelry
this ring this one harbors the soul of
your last lover
that doesn't fit me it only fits this
finger which is frankly triggering
this is a green tiger's eye mommy loves
her tiger
that's made up this is the nipple ring
no this is not a nipple ring
this is a bloodstone winter letter from
hogwarts coming in
this is a ring that i had made of one of
my dogs that's my dog daisy
this is what happens when nobody loves
you
and you have no one to love here's my
favorite
vintage horse ring here's my second
favorite horseshoe ring
my third favorite horseshoe ring which i
got at a vintage store
in england i know what you're thinking
most people don't have three different
favorite horseshoe rings
these are my favorite horseshoe earrings
which i would be wearing if i wasn't
wearing my
horse earrings
cool it's my wolf ring that i wear on
first dates to make sure guys never call
me back
i wore this in my second stand-up
special i love you
there's a horse who guessed it tiger's
eye
wolf what if you just disappeared
i had a paint horse growing up same
that is a horse i painted when i was
five who's this that's me wow
yeah good big planet where are you going
[Laughter]
to go make a vaccine i don't see a
french braid and then
we get naked and they see that my pubes
are french braided
this is the nicest thing i own but i
don't know what it is
yes this is full this is um
this is full this is if whitney had her
own rock of love
this is if whitney had a full mid-life
crisis which is
any minute this is my favorite bear
i think that's from montana this is my
second
favorite bear which gas station in
montana
they're buddies
i know i miss you too who needs kids
oh i love this necklace i got this at a
thrift store i want to say in austin
texas isn't that good i love that oh
lucky me carrie yes
carrick sex in the city yes she had this
remember it prom the blood
no she dark this is a movie
this is a rorschach test that benton
failed this is just
so symbolic this is like my life in a
nutshell
oh look at this another horse ball old
horse jewelry
shit if we've learned anything today
it's that i'm a hoarder
michael patrick king gave this to me
after we made two bro girls and i
lost it and then i got a white tattoo of
it because i was so heartbroken that i
lost it
and then i found it and i was like shit
where'd you find it
inside me fine
this is a necklace that an ex-boyfriend
gave me uh
correction threw at me and after we
broke up
i thought i'm gonna throw this right
back at him
and i was like you know what the best
thing i can do is just keep it keep the
jewelry ladies so i kept this and i put
this horse charm on it
which goes with this horse they're in a
little hurdle okay he just bought you
this part of it
yeah just this part oh and then i was
like i'm gonna like
give this back to him to show him who's
boss
does he work in hot topic this is
another little tray i have but it's got
a dog on it
is that cody uh i think it's a wolf
or a dog and it's got a necklace in it
with an r on it which stands for ramona
on my dog
one of my dogs i'm not even gonna say a
joke about that this is serious
and it gets its own little dog bowl this
is from
france this is a
fight this is you're getting very tired
of hearing about horses
isn't that pretty and it's pretty and
then you can also do this to kind of
make it more of a choker if you want to
be like sexual
be like i like that uh the more
successful you get the less new things
you buy
yeah i don't like new things i only like
old things that have like
you can feel it it's got some history to
it i feel like uh
a long-suffering woman was in a terrible
marriage wearing this
it says in the back let's
which is french for you're gonna die
alone i bought all the horse charms on
etsy
so i had to move on to wolves what is
this someone
literally went to joann's fabric bought
all the beads and made this
i don't like your attitude coming from
the person wearing a kabala bracelet
with a little eyeball on it this was a
sponsor
okay love that bracelet i would like to
support whatever toddler made this
necklace
it looks good i think it's cute i feel
like i look like trouble couples photos
i look like um the lady at yoga class
that might steal your man
like i'm like after two lemon cellos
she's trouble
i don't know who what life i think
i have they're all covered in like clam
chowder
that's a good bit these are from the 70s
which probably means i'm giving myself
head lice
these are vintage fairy f-e-r-r-e
made in italy aren't these amazing
i know i just i know it's a little like
kanye west
again one of my elton john i was like
i'm gonna wear these to a wedding and
people are gonna like like me
and i'm gonna like stay late and not
like she's a brick
house like i'm gonna be the girl on the
dance floor
never happened um yeah
yeah these are hideously ugly did i buy
these who did they think i was
i gotta leave lay
even though i don't think i have the
self-esteem or confidence to actually
wear these for more than five minutes i
love them
those look great you think yeah no
they're too skinny i feel like they're
gonna
like puncture me or something aviators
was like look at me and my aviators like
i know like i'm 30 days off cocaine
hang out you know what i need in here a
fridge a friend
thirsty one of my favorite shirts
great first date shirt my favorite
indoor outfit
if you want to make sure neighbors never
come over
or try to talk to you oh this is my
horse bathing suit that i keep on a
hanger because it's so precious to me
see there's a horse right on the vagina
right there
that is a very strong statement my
vagina has horsepower
lots of like boys jackets from the 70s
that i buy
like 70s vests i love these
how cute is that yeah very cute this
jacket
not me that was my iud sorry
how great are these and all these
zippers i love this jacket but i haven't
worn it because i'm afraid comedians are
going to make fun of me
and call me lemony snicket this i had
big plans for this
you wore it all the time to the store
before we got on lockdown it was
great this was my big play to be
warmer because i always wear those like
dark like olive green cargo jackets
i wore this in my hbo no special which
was
i don't think they let me have it
i think it i stole it we might need to
cut this
i want so bad i just like i want to be a
corduroy blazer person i can never pull
it off
it's just so like sexy annie hall like
like
solid black sweater like take me
seriously
like i direct but i also act and i'm a
comedian
and like i move the props around the
muppets
this is like um what i wear when i think
a guy's gonna leave me
it's a very short skirt and i'll just
wear it around the house and be like
what
huh this i wore i was wearing when i
found out my dad died
you know you can never was this the
reason he died what
did he see you in that and he was like
he died of embarrassment
this is my favorite thing like a fancy
fanny pack
by claire vivier that cute what do you
keep in there
well berries i can't
i haven't really used it yet so she
loves it it's this is my favorite bag
[Music]
i bought that one oh that's a great one
and i bought this
i don't know when i could wear this it's
a skirt with a matching top
hey want to go do ayahuasca and mexico
i think it's cute isn't it it's a little
bit like
this looks like a doily this looks like
something that goes on a couch to not
get it dirty
what is this this is a top this is a fun
no tropical top i could wear it on and
out of epstein island
this is a um custom-made moo moo and
this is a picture of your horse that's
my piece
i need this i have to have this well
what what but it was and i said are you
sure it's 400
and you said i need it and i said okay
this is a horse robe
i think it's just what you wear to sleep
with married men
it goes well with a yacht which i don't
have like i feel like i need uh not yet
but if you buy that merch
store.whitneycummings.com
i watched mine hunter i got so obsessed
with the lady agents
coat this is actually what i mentioned
and you were selling pocket watches out
of it
here's the flasher who lives next door
yeah why can't i just wear this around
without people thinking i'm
a sex worker hora the explorer
it's got zebras and cheetahs and monkeys
on it
buddy and lions i'm going on like kelly
and ryan yeah
how cute you guys don't know about those
but whitney's actually remaking dynasty
you shop like a hot girl look
nope you've always been this attractive
that when you buy clothes you're like
this will work on me
thank you what about this bathmat even i
will admit this was a blender try it on
the logical next step
of my evolution as a single woman
um who makes her own soap it's what a
conservative mom would wear on a
carnival cruise
you say it as if it's an insult we just
need to take it in a bit
because you want to take it into the
camera or the zebra this shirt is
waterproof
and somehow flammable oh my god did you
see that part
i did look there's tassels on the zebra
tail
fuck okay now point out where it's cute
this is what you wear when you're
meeting your third husband's family
you wore this on um conan conan cows
dogs deer
tigers you're like if noah's ark was a
person
you're like if jealousy was a person
thank you i have tried to wear this
outfit numerous times
jealous haters keep sabotaging me and
discouraging me from doing it
i call them friends two horse
sweaters yeah it's a little founding
fathers
the goal is to wear this in my next
special if
that ever gets to happen i mean you're
not a wrapper
[Music]
yeah my dog shirt my
cheetah shirt other cheetah shirt
it's my other horse
you want to borrow it when something
works i like to just get it in every
color no when did this work
this oh i thought that was a towel
elephant shirt
horse vintage horse shirt another horse
shirt
this just goes on and on
[Music]
cheetah shirt bugs
safari blues off other safari blues off
that's not diaphanous
my other tiger shirt that i loved dog
shirt
wild safari vibes don't touch it didn't
i wear this on something those stars
snow
we haven't really found a moment yet for
it
this i also love this shirt she has four
of them isn't that cute
like like annie hall on molly i wore
that on dates to let men know that i
am wife material and she added a stone
for everyone that left
i wore this shirt to every meeting for
years i love this and this is glitter
glue
and this jacket was what uh lots of
money
all my favorite vintage sweatshirts on
them with the random thong
for november oh my undies i've been
looking for those actually oh
my favorite horse bolero if a guy starts
liking me too much i'll just start
wearing this around
vintage wolf sweatshirt people were
really losing their minds on the
internet
the designer for the loom this is
givenchy
what she's a fashion icon
it is standing in this position on its
own it's very stiff
it's definitely a cum ring that cute
charming look at me
i'm fashion forward but also down to
earth i got this on etsy before you
we're back to 2002. do you want it this
is an echo scarf that i wore a lot when
i was in college and i
i was very jackie oh i felt very
fancy i made a lot of mistakes in this
scarf
you're like a fortune teller i wish i
had been able to read the future back
then
saved me a lot of doctor's appointments
i know what that is
it's definitely blood this is good for
you um all for charity
you can get this at
store.winningcommons.com my favorite
if you're going what you don't have them
in high tops
fuck out of here person
wearing them right now truly
you could always wear these in case
you're a dog person
you can release now when did you take
over the playboy mansion
these are vintage boots that have belts
around that
ankles these are cute i've yet to find
something they really match but i love
them
yeah i don't shoes i get bored i have
like a whole other jewelry section
i forgot about this cute it's a great
one these were my thanksgiving
pie earrings that i forgot about so i
have to wait another fucking year
am i just desert scene necklace
got some lady in a moo moo on it it's
the virgin mary oh
for when christmas happens when he loves
christmas i love christmas
oh oh it gets worse it's more
embarrassing
this is actually really sad that i have
so many christmas earrings
i thought this was the coolest necklace
on the planet
it's a great way to let people know like
i'm emotionally unavailable
nothing is more whitney in this closet
than this sign that says everything
popular is wrong and the irony is that
it's
was said by oscar wilde who's very
popular
joking tree scented perfume which i wear
year round really brings me back to my
childhood just
glasses of eggnog flying across the room
with people's heads
tiger by her side caroline
sounds like exotic animal trafficking
cowboy grass
it's a little bit like um it smells a
little bit like a taint
i do have some remnants of like back
when i was like fun and
like go clubbing oh my god just so much
gum
and appeal in a random pill
can you take it so we can find out what
it is by the way numerous types of gum
it's literally like it's not even
chewing it's like breaking up into
pieces
look at me like i'm so low maintenance
like all i need is a lip balm and
my cell phone and that's it like let's
go apple cooking
i love this one here's the theme
oh oh look going through old purses is
very fruitful
i thought this was the coolest thing on
the planet i wore this everywhere i went
made a lot of mistakes with this first
let's see what's inside the first one
was buying it
oh yeah my cheer sweatshirt voila
this was a big deal this purse
we should do a giveaway
[Music]
half a peanut butter bar in it
stevia anyone i'm really learning a lot
about myself
this is my like going out first oh
excuse me this just has one old tampon
i thought this was like x it's like very
vintage
matrix vintage patent leather very loud
you're just talking to people and you're
just like making
like fart noises lots of fart noises
i wore this all the time to try to make
people think that i was like
i really thought i was this person at
the wedding i'm like hey guys
okay single stable
whitney what about all your pajamas
i thought you'd never ask these are my
snake jams doggy jam jams look at this
little chow chow
bull terrier um hairless thing
look at the sharpie on the back poodle i
thought that was me
flamingo jam jams i love these you like
the flamingos
my colored zebra jam jams because it
reminds me of the end of wizard of oz
when the horses were all colored
my tiger jam jams that have a giant hole
in the butt
because you know why pooping there's
that
see this is why it's not petting my
stomach i'm not a buddha statue
this is why i don't allow men to sleep
in my bed my pajamas are too fancy and i
don't want them to ruin them yeah
i feel like my pajama collection has
gotten a little sunset boulevard
your pajama collection is that of the
oldest gay man
he owns palm springs
[Music]
we don't want to miss out on this the
fat tiger yeah come on if you really
want to
lure in men or blind
i buy a lot of nice bras it's just they
never
it just never happens for me i have big
plans for this bra now
what are your plans to wear it as a jock
shop
no next podcast this is my outfit next
podcast
these are important to me these are
socks with my dogs on them and i've
never worn them
there is something i love even more
socks with my horse on them
do i need a psychiatrist
socks of me with a cowboy hat on
you know what the socks the other socks
of my horse with carrots i have all i
need
oh was this a success
[Music]
okay well can you please leave so i can
cry
it's 6 15. this is about the time i
get in fetal position and cry in my
closet so